We will spend a lot of time in this class referring to Reddit.
You know, we've used it as database examples,
I refer to the system architecture, things we did,
and I've referred the mistakes I've
made over the years on Reddit.
I'm going to kind of take from the top how we
built Reddit and how we grew it over the years
and then I'm going to talk with Neil, who
is the current lead engineer of Reddit,
and he is going to talk about how they taken over
since I've left, which is a couple of years ago now,
and continued to grow all the site
as it has grown tremendously.
So we started in June 2005--
me and my co-founder, my college roommate,
his name is Alexis Ohanian.
I was the engineer and Alexis was
our kind of everything-else guy.
He paid the rent. He did the business-guy
stuff. He did the marketing things.
He was my sounding board for future ideas.
He did design work for Reddit.
Him and I basically lived Reddit for
the first 2 years, the two of us.
When we started, the first vision
of Reddit was written in Lisp,
which is an actually very old programming
language, one of the first ones.
I think it was originally invented in '50s.
It is still one of those powerful languages.
It is very fun to develop in.
One of the other professors here in Udacity, Peter
Norvig, is one of the world's Lisp experts
and a couple of his books are
extremely good on the topic of Lisp.
It is more popular out set universities than it is
in the real world, it's really need to working.
During this time, we had variable traffic,
but everything was in Lisp--
our Handlers, as you'd expect. Our HTML
was all generated by Lisp.
Our CSS was all generated by Lisp. Javascript.
Lisp is a language that lands itself to
generating other languages
and other pieces of code really, really nicely.
I'm not to get in to the details of it, but Lisp
was all we had. We had Lisp plus Postgres.
We didn't have any memcached at that time. I've just
stored everything in an in-memory hash table.